[Música]
y por supuesto vamos a ampliar entonces
todo lo que ocurrió ese 13 de noviembre
del año 2015 a quien lo su cubrimiento
especial de directo américa de france 24
ponemos en contexto con laurel que está
con nosotros aquí en el estudio de
periodista de la reacción de france a 24
le ha muy buen día buenos días tablet
pongamos entonces nuestra audiencia en
contexto explicaros un poco sobre los
atentados de este juicio histórico
exactamente raúl entonces para contar
todo bien el 3 de noviembre de 2015 todo
empezó al inicio del partido de fútbol
de francia compra alemania son las 9 y
16 y un primer ruido en ser sede dor
resuena fuera del estadio en sami en las
afueras de parís ella es el primer
terrorista suicida que acaba direccionar
su cinturón de explosivos unos minutos
después el segundo y el tercer
terrorista suicida activaron sus
cinturones de explosivos mataron a una
persona e hirieron a 63 otras al mismo
momento pero más al sur en los 2 10 y 11
de parís un segundo comando de tres
hombres arremetieron contra las terrazas
de varios bares y restaurantes con más
de 400 disparos de rifles kalashnikov en
20 minutos mataron a 39 personas e
hirieron a decenas
pero lea esto no no no es el fin de
digamos estos atentados lamentablemente
no lamentablemente no porque a las nueve
y cuarenta un tercer grupo de
terroristas llegó a la sala de
espectáculos del bataclán también en el
distrito 11 de la capital dentro 1500
personas asistían a un concierto de la
banda rock eagles of death metal el
primero los terroristas mataron a tiros
a la gente al exterior de la sala antes
de entrar y disparar contra los
espectadores algunos lograron escaparse
por las salidas de emergencias o
esconderse en las salas del edificio
muchos murieron inmediatamente uno de
los tres terroristas fue abatido y allí
para los supervivientes a las diez y
veinte comenzó una toma de rehenes
llegaron innumerables policías fuerzas
especiales bomberos y otros servicios de
emergencia intentaron negociar pero no
funcionó el asalto final se dio entonces
a las 12 y 18 y el error terminó a las
1258 cuando los dos últimos terroristas
fueron abatidos y que la evacuación de
los heridos comenzó de ahí también son
los segundos atentados más mortíferos de
europa después de madrid de 2004
estos ataques de noviembre de 2015 en
francia se cree un contexto bien
particular no si era el es que el año
2015 quedará en francia como un año
tristemente marcado por múltiples
ataques terroristas ya en enero tres
atentados azotaron al país el 7 de enero
primero el ataque contra el periódico
satírico charlie hebdo donde murieron 12
personas incluidos dibujantes y
periodistas conocidos al qaida
reivindicó el tiroteo y luego el 8 de
enero el asesinato de una policía y el 9
de enero la toma de rehenes de clientes
de un supermercado kosher donde cuatro
personas murieron son raúl tres ataques
en tres días que pusieron el país en un
estado de alerta total el resto del año
2015 fue marcado por otros atentados
puntuales o intentos de atentado hasta
llegar a este 13 de noviembre pero
además del terrible balance humano
ciento y 30 personas muertas el 13 de
noviembre son atentados que
traumatizaron a francia porque se
dirigieron estos atentados
específicamente a la juventud de parís a
la gente que asiste a un partido de
fútbol por ejemplo en el estado y
formosa la gente que sale a tomar tragos
y a comer en restaurantes no sé si lo
sabes raúl pero estos dos distritos el
10 y el 11 son conocidos por su vida
nocturna muy rica y diversa son varios
donde mucha gente va y viene para
también asistir a eventos culturales
como este concierto en el bataclán donde
murieron 90 personas son lugares del
cotidiano para muchas personas sobre
todo en un país como francia que tiene
una fuerte cultura de las terrazas
el contraste entre esta vida cotidiana y
la violencia de estos ataques
perpetrados con armas de guerra es lo
que muchos médicos testificaron después
del 3 en noviembre que estas armas eran
de guerra que estas heridas normalmente
se ven solo en terrenos de conflicto por
lo que los terroristas utilizado en cara
chicos bueno es este contraste que
traumatizó al final al país claro le
amas usted estaba en parís cuando
ocurrió esta noche estábamos conversando
anteriormente y también tenía amigos
pues en esta sala de concierto en este
distrito obviamente de bares y
restaurantes en parís o imagino que pues
la experiencia tuvo que ser bastante
dura en su momento también cuando pues
era pues una adolescente que solamente
quería divertirse no todavía le antes de
continuar digamos para pasar algo
histórico se siente ese tipo de miedo
que qué contexto digamos el sentimiento
se siente entre el entre la juventud
francesa entre sus amigos entre usted lo
que puedo decir es que la juventud
volvió al asteras hubo unas semanas de
miedo total de detención que se sentía
en la ciudad de parís pero ahora somos
67 años después de estos atentados
eso es lo bueno de esta residencia lo
que se puede encontrar en cada persona
es que la gente volvió a salir y también
fue como señales de resistencia de una
cierta manera a estos para ir en contra
de estos terroristas que querían sembrar
como semillas del miedo en
todas las personas al final la gente
sigue tiene que seguir a vivir su vida
claro y vivir la vida y puedes no
dejarse intimidar y amenazar por el
terrorismo y vivir nuestra vida en
libertad ahora que tenemos digamos todos
estos elementos le a que viene usted
explicaba este juicio comenzó el 8 de
septiembre del año pasado 6 años después
de los atentados y también el objetivo
ya el adjetivo más utilizado para
calificarlo es el juicio histórico el
megajuicio histórico porque es porque
raúl es el juicio de todos los récords
primero son más de cinco años de una
titánica investigación de instrucción e
instrucción por parte de los expertos
policiales y judiciales estuvieron entre
otras cosas quieren construir la
logística completa de los atentados
desde
ruta por europa de los miembros de los
tres comandos hasta sus escondites
alquilados en bélgica y cerca de parís y
hablando de construcción para asumir el
reto de acoger por turnos a las
2500 personas que se constituyeron como
parte civil a los 330 abogados y a los
centenares de periodistas nacionales e
internacionales a créditos para cubrir
el juicio
bueno construyeron especialmente una
sala de audiencia monumental en el
antiguo palacio de justicia de parís y
habilitaron entonces a las anexas más
pequeñas pero de las de los 2500
participantes todos no podían ir hasta
parís oa veces no querían porque era
demasiado doloroso entonces crearon
también una radio virtual especial otra
cosa era una nueva herramienta de este
juicio de más de 800 personas que
utilizaron al menos una vez desde el
inicio del juicio en septiembre este
sistema se renovará para el juicio del
atentado del 14 de julio de 2016 en
insta que cobró 86 víctimas
y nueve nacionales nacionalidades
diferentes y que comenzará en el país en
xico del 5 de septiembre es que sí
le quería preguntar antes de continuar
si este juicio penal es el más largo en
historia judicial francesa posguerra si
eso es raúl y es que bueno diez meses al
final no puede parecer muy largo pero no
eran demasiado para escuchar a todos
estos protagonistas en este en este
sentido hay periodistas que hablaron de
un maratón jurídico además de las
víctimas los cinco jueces de este
tribunal especial tienen que juzgar a 20
personas eso también es
enorme por su contribución de los
atentados pero sólo 14 acusados se
presentaron durante el juicio los otros
seis son juzgados en ausencia a cinco
están muertos al menos es lo que es lo
que se supone y uno está detenido en
turquía y rechazó su extradición